-Performing
"Dreaming of the Past"
from his new album,
"It's Almost Dry,"
give it up for Pusha T!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ I was dreaming of the past ♪
-♪ It's levels, it's layers,
so pray for the players, unh ♪
♪ We hollowed the walls in
the back of bodegas, unh ♪
-♪ I got plenty ♪
♪ It's so many, yeah ♪
♪ They say, "Gimme" ♪
♪ He got plenty, yeah ♪
-♪ Bro, you...ain't flexin',
you crampin' ♪
♪ My weight keep a...on
their bikes like Amblin ♪
♪ Weight loss, rent loss,
they're scramblin' ♪
♪ Now pass the champagne
to the champion ♪
♪ My...get money, get money,
get money like Ye samplin' ♪
♪ Gun stutter, make the drum
line like Grambling ♪
♪ MGM, gamblin',
blew a small mansion ♪
♪ Annoyed 'cause this chick
callin' Lanvin "Lan-vin" ♪
♪ What, who you stampin',
them...just stand-ins ♪
♪ Not me,
they censor and block me ♪
♪ You hollerin', "Top five,"
I only see top me ♪
♪ Award shows the only way
you...could rob me ♪
♪ It's levels, it's layers,
so pray for the players ♪
♪ Clip 'em, baby, if he flinch
at the price of Bottega, unh ♪
-♪ I got plenty ♪
♪ It's so many, yeah ♪
♪ They say, "Gimme" ♪
♪ He got plenty, yeah ♪
-♪ Bro, you...ain't drip,
you dryin' ♪
♪ Kevlar in his
Balenciaga jacket linin' ♪
♪ You and your chick
income-combinin' ♪
♪ I'm sending' Lorraine Schwartz
diamond minin' ♪
♪ Find 'em ♪
♪ I came up with Enzo Drifters ♪
♪ So you gots to understand
there's a difference ♪
♪ There's window stickers
and window lickers ♪
♪ You know the type ♪
♪ Always tryna
get in your picture ♪
♪ I was tryna get the
dope through, in your sister ♪
♪ We won baggin' up the work,
wouldn't be no dishes ♪
♪ Be no Christmas,
mistletoe, be no kisses ♪
♪ Made a way for ourselves,
we ain't need no wishes, ha ♪
♪ It's levels, it's layers,
so pray for the players, unh ♪
♪ We hollowed the walls in
the back of bodegas, unh ♪
-♪ I got plenty ♪
♪ It's so many, yeah ♪
♪ They say, "Gimme" ♪
♪ He got plenty, yeah ♪
-♪ Walk it down, like Brady,
gets better with time ♪
♪ Didn't have to reinvent the
wheel, just a better design ♪
♪ Critics,
"He's out of his mind" ♪
♪ Haters,
"He's outta his prime" ♪
♪ Yet, always where the money's
at like lottery signs ♪
♪ Still I climb, rock star,
Third Eye Blind ♪
♪ I was bored by these albums,
so it gotta be time ♪
♪ No reward for the latter,
so it gotta be mine ♪
♪ Huff and puff in the club,
then I gotta be shine ♪
♪ It's levels, it's layers,
so pray for the players, unh ♪
♪ We hollowed the walls in
the back of bodegas, unh ♪
-♪ I got plenty ♪
♪ It's so many, yeah ♪
♪ They say, "Gimme" ♪
♪ He got plenty, yeah ♪
-♪ Unh ♪
-♪ And my heart
was beating fast ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"It's Almost Dry," out now.
Rap Album of the Year.